io
[Musica]
vj originals oggi ragazzi in questo
video voluto approfondire uno sport che
da sempre mi interessa provare la
scherma siccome l'unica pratica che ho
fatto in vita mia è stato a guardare
sword art on line ci viene incontro
alessandra che è stata campionessa di
scherma e inoltre proviene da una
famiglia di schermo schermi
come cazzo si dice beppe
schermi schermito schermidori scusa c'è
un modo per
fare il proprio fiorino
scusami ma io ho visto una cosa che mi
ha fatto molto ridere magari da bambini
vestiamoci
[Musica]
ecco veramente molto però così forse far
la spesa non mi conosce nessuno secco io
non sono paura incredibile va bene
posizione la camera
che coincidenza esattamente su chi si
sentirà all'ospedale ventimiglia
[Musica]
beh
allora
[Musica]
[Applauso]
i ragazzi dopo un po di riscaldamento
passiamo alla partita vera e propria si
arriva a 5 let's go
si
gusta il titolo luogo
[Musica]
scorre
cos'ha fatto
capito perché
grazie alla mattina
e quindi ragazzi
i due maestri alla fine si confrontano
ci mascheriamo amico milano è stato
bello conoscere
[Musica]
be nice
e non è territorio di punti magia
io
no
dopo video 20 euro
[Musica]
campione di scherma i tory ragazzi
questo video e va beh grazie gianni fa
niente faceva parte dello scherzo video
sullo schermo è finito e hanno già fatto
una foto della nostra del nostro
combattimento hanno visto la bellissima
volevo ringraziare al e che si è
prestata a guardare due che tentano di
schermo touch da 1 a 10 a merlo
78 giampiero che non ho mai preso il
sodo come si scrive madonna stai
veramente ma ti prego dammi
lavorerò ragazzi veri uomini sono così
sei studi ci vediamo a bracciano ragazzi